un gioco bello come sono contento di
essere tornato su sta roba
i ragazzi di questo momento sono
famiglia ci siamo dati su geometri dash
la copia esatta di the impossible game
dedicata alla gente alla quale non piace
andare a messa la domenica siccome
ragazzi i livelli che faccio di solito i
geometri dash fanno cagare facciamo una
roba un po più easy più sono veramente
sono super contento di provare un mi
sembra di essere sotto effetto di acidi
un attimo a che livello scelto rave
fermi si va beh sì ma magari un po più
un po più facile
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] sto facendo tutto ciò fin
eni l'autostrada bellissimo per rifare
fermi che ci siamo fermi ma che abc
[Musica]
ma come faccio a ben
no no ora farò un livello che si sa che
è un po più difficile ma fattibile
almeno fattibile
almeno quello
scherzavo il tutto così sto gioco noi
vogliamo così incasinato geometri la sua
porca put allora porca eva lercia meno
li vedo neanche si cosi sono troppo
piccoli sui triangoli porca vacca
ok proviamo a fare la madonna questo
cos'è solo vedere solo è solo vedere per
curiosità solo vedere
[Musica]
che figata che figata vabbè no vabbè
bellissimo peccato però che sia
impossibile
sono arrivato più avanti in questo che
nell'altro però
[Musica]
che figata regala va bè ragazzi proviamo
a fare un livello più adatto alle nostre
esigenze molto più easy decisamente più
easy c'è anche scritto dove devi saltare
grazie a di chi dice anche cosa devi
fare ti li premuto grazie per deficienti
queste perle ci riesce anche mia nonna
far esprimere però vabbè mica in un
tentativo ragazzi potrei finirlo pensate
[Musica]
ok forse potrei e non ho detto ecco
infatti perché io parco porca eva per
chiedo perché setini prega ama che figo
la mia persona è un robot non ho mica
visto le fighissima sta roba
secondo me i ragazzi sto livello ci sta
ancora meglio la canzone dell'ora esatta
non so perché
[Musica]
ei no però ci siamo noi a 6 c a schiphol
col demonio perché io leggo portava dai
dai dai dai dai
perfetto oddio cos'è natale e spider man
il rutto cos'è sta roba elf ci ho fatto
fino alla fine ok perfetto è il livello
per mongoloidi solo se ha portati a casa
va bene posso anche fibra il video è un
video bello adesso apre a farne uno un
po più difficile non come quelli di
prima ma più difficile di questo almeno
ma ma tutti scuri sti livelli non è che
sono razzista con con i livelli e pro
pezzo di merda che [ __ ] sta roba che va
a tempo perché mi fa impazzire
ok questo non è facile
cioè nel senso questo era era già ok era
già classificato come un più difficile
normale quindi
ok ok ok ok perfetto no porco
perfetto
[Musica]
calmi
questo nuovo fare la non ho capito che
ai fermi fermi fermi fermi fermi
[Musica]
qua dai tratti ne sto facendo con cose
non sto capendo anche io la sto facendo
[Musica]
ma perché non riesco fu la cosa che devo
fare il tutto rimane non riuscire a fare
[Musica]
ma cos'ha sbagliato vi sono molto dove
dove cosa non sarà un po vena vabbè dove
sono dove non sono morto non so non ho
toccato nulla non ho toccato niente cosa
dove e esploso da era bellissima voce
una roba assurda gatto mi fa un sacco
piacere che tu stai giocando a livo
words tantissimo solo che no
[Musica]
o papà
ma io so io credo fermi cos'è e vabbè il
bordello queste facile facile facile fin
qui come facile ce la faccio
[Musica]
ok mi piace aperto vai vai vai addio di
aiuti alla città ma come si taglia
taglia questa parte inediti in italia
tutto è tagliatutto bei ragazzi io sono
fortissimo questo grazie spero che vi
sia piaciuto questo gioco bello che ho
fatto io pero vi abbiate capito come si
gioca al geometri dash grazie a un
maestro come me che vi insegna a giocare
perché io ogni tanto faccio anche queste
sessioni di video dove faccio vedere che
un sacco di esperienza nel mondo
videoludico e quindi posso darvi una
mano
lasciate mi piace qui i ragazzi spero
che questo sia piaciuto cose se questo
commento mi piace anche ai vari social
che come descrizione senza figli siete
lì ci vediamo al prossimo vito era
ragazzi
[Musica]